how you guys doing it's been a while I'm
excited for this video let's check it
out what do you guys been up to how's
your life excellent
I hate great glad you're doing great
leave your memes on the Reddit 19 year
old now
true 19 year old do you think that you
will overtake T-Series easily I'll get
revenge for I spent I'm like
Please Mr Beast kill them no no no no no
no no I'm actually above this I don't
think I don't engage with subscriber
Wars I don't think this is good at all
hey
[Applause]
looks oh still got it that's a good
picture and we got Maya oh thank you
Jubilee you're the goat
that's such a oh that's so sweet oh my
God
that's so nice thing I actually really
appreciate it I'm an Australian visiting
Sweden
why why would you do that
and found a photo of Gloria Porter from
peonies among 100 people that Changed
History A friend of mine sent me this he
was like what the [__] my mom as well
it's kind of crazy
I'm up there wait there I am hey oh
hey hey right next to slaughter yeah I'm
honored thank you we changed history
guys we did it that's [__] nuts to
think of Jesus Christ I think that's so
distant from the YouTube thing that a
lot of stuff hasn't you know it doesn't
register to me
it's like what the [__] who's that oh I
think especially looking back like I
want to do YouTube I Hate My School
it turned out okay enjoy interrupting
this video to let you know about today's
sponsor which of course is you got it
not just because it has Nord in it
I swear I've been using nordvpn daily
for years now keeping me getting access
to the entire internet as it should be
but no VPN goes way and above to protect
you online with amazing features as
threat protection and now also dark web
monitor dark web scary place previously
if you sign up to a website and that
website gets hacked you're compromised
and you might not even find out about it
nordvpn got your back they're constantly
scanning this for you let's get real
here you sign up to a lot of weird
websites it's okay
your VPN does all this job for you and
scans the dark web and lets you know if
there's been a compromise leak so you
can always sleep easily and know that
ignored VPN just got your bag they're
always announcing new cool features they
also have mentioned it now would you
like to access your computer files from
anywhere turning your own computer into
VPN kind of but you get a huge discount
on a two-year deal if you sign up with
my link in the description nordvpn.com
PewDiePie click the goddamn link because
you also and on top of that get one
additional month for free you're welcome
we got a deal at only if you use the
link all right
thank you novpn for sponsoring this
video I don't understand how he kept
going
Felix after the video ended okay all
right I'm glad this has been brought up
because I need to settle this with
everyone because I think everyone's got
the wrong idea you can't get I mean I'm
not 100 sure about this
you can't get sunburned through a window
right uh ah
okay it is possible it doesn't happen as
quickly okay see every [__] time all
my friends like ow my window is so I'm
gonna like five it's five
it's through a window it's not as
effective I understand that it still
will be some but it's not so bad so stop
being babies you're all a bunch of
babies not you but my past friends that
I don't speak to anymore I don't want to
say isn't on YouTube anymore but I have
video of them just making raviolis
together would be nice to watch because
it seems like such a daunting task I've
actually helped them make ravioli she
has one of those uh pasta machines I
don't
she made something delicious today which
I forgot I asked what it was called but
it was handmade pasta and it was
delicious she's an amazing Chef I want
to watch Gordon Ramsay with Mercy I
think that would be fun
this is a classic I'm honestly a little
jealous of this tattoo I kind of want it
for myself that's big PP look can you do
this should I get it I I wasn't like
some video I will get tattoo actually I
don't know I think it's Crackle
so dumb [__] dead meme tattoo it's
funny I don't know how Gordon Ramsay
like this is one of those figures that
managed to he's such an [__] but he's
so wholesome at the same time it's
everything I aspire to be I love it yo
since everyone is sharing gym progress
here's mine damn looking good bro I
think we'll see this later because I got
some in my feed it's really cool
actually people were started posting
their gym progress uh I'm all about that
okay now I just get the people uh
complaining of that
people complaining about it I saw the
goat today apparently it survived this
year next year booking I'm coming for
you I can't believe it yeah there it is
it didn't burn
[Music]
I was trying to send signal to you guys
to [__] burn it down what is this
Austin Bradley got a baby that's so cute
congratulations man I actually got a 3D
printer and I've been loving it you
gotta teach me some tricks mate bad
stuff a song about a 33 year old
marriage Swedish men wanted to freaking
crazy
yeah
I mean love that big poopy found this
license plating face
diet can I have it please it's really
hard to get those approved or is it easy
I have no idea I never tried because I'm
not American that's why okay so I
complained about daylight savings time
and that we need to change it a year ago
and now it's finally happened in
Washington congratulations Washington
here we go thank you PewDiePie for
changing my life is about it I waited 85
pounds six years ago after almost dying
from diabetes type one with your
inspiration from you I now weigh 185
pounds I can overhead press 155 pounds
for three by five sets I feel much
better in general and about myself now
so thank you very much hell yeah amazing
what a Chan love to see it big PP see
this is such an amazing fan art is it AI
does it have art in the no I believe you
I believe you
believe me
I love it thank you so much do you feel
break cheers bro
you make me spell idiot always G fuel
I turned 19 today I had a beauty pie
cake everyone has to have a PewDiePie
kick at their 19th birthday
it's all downhill from there guys trust
me that's so cool
all right I'd say I art I don't believe
it another one what the [__] no longer
19. now you get one take I just
explained it
this is my progression yes happier now
all right we'll find them as long as
you're still lifting I don't care what
you look like
me after watching PewDiePie have like
knowing my life will never be as perfect
as this now guys this is all like my
washing machine broke the other week I
had to do my own dishes
yeah we're not the same
my life is hard my one year gym
progression I'm also 19 in a few days so
just in time guys
the before is on the left you have to
put that before left then my god do I
have to explain this to you Jesus Christ
great progression though
me waiting for my prayers guests to
leave so I can come downstairs and grab
some food we I remember me and Chris are
to be funny if I eat something weird
because we're going to that place but
like it was drifting a bunch of stuff
from the ceiling and I swear I swear I
dripped in my Sushi and after eating it
I felt so weird I'm like I'm gonna turn
I'm zombie anytime I'm turning into a
zombie I know it
hey even female Bros got games hell yeah
love to see a big peepee
impressive
try bouldering Japan is ducking good at
the bowling yeah actually Conor told me
about a really good place in Akihabara I
want to try it out actually is that
bouldering if it's inside can you do
bouldering inside because I I'm not
doing that that's not happening
he doesn't know how to take a compliment
yeah it was almost like just
all right I'll give you a big peepee for
the nice message that's how we'll do
that
10 kids playing it
[Laughter]
sweet like he just wants to see how his
kids are doing and we just turned it
into something weird
yeah it doesn't get better than that
giving my mouse kind of bad because it
doesn't fit in the washing machine this
is actually pretty smart I should do
that they're too big now I usually put
them in the dishwasher thinking I was
smart but that makes more sense did it
come out okay like did it start
threading or something
can't tell if this is a meme it looks
like you have no arms it's a meme right
but but everything in the in the header
makes it seem like it's not I'm
profinely aggressive arms
he cured his eyesight okay answer me
I don't get it I I still I'm not
convinced
oh very sweet thank you how me and my
boyfriend celebrate in the years like
intellectuals hell yeah oh you're
watching in my intellectual video book
video book that's right that's what it's
called thank you I usually do a ton of
fireworks and I can't do it in Japan
it was sad but if I missed the needle in
the Swiss army knife I I know I haven't
I just forgot to show it
don't man explain uh Swiss Army names to
me okay don't ever do that again small
PPP I know you're just trying to help so
I'll give you a big peepee but I resent
clicking it don't ever switch to Army
knives explain me again
uh 166 kilo Squad yeah big peepee 505
pound Squad
a lot of people growing into their
PewDiePie marriage so here's me growing
out of mine 117 down to 83 kill is still
counting
whoa
that actually tripped me out so people
are imposing memes I can't tell you look
so different oh you got the the Devilman
Cry Baby extra based since everyone is
posting progression thanks I I think
it's good to acknowledge like working
out that's the best for your mental
health it really does it's great to show
progress and be proud of it and I think
it's great to celebrate but like let's
not forget why you should do it extend
your life spanning and avoid disease and
all that
[Music]
okay
I kind of love how that became a thing
everyone seemed annoyed by it that's
because you they are not lifting start
lifting immediately you go and then
you're both that's it this is a true
intellectual meme that only
0.001 of people will ever understand
I've Dishonored my family I'm sorry Papa
the countries why do I not know what
that's called in English thumbstock what
the [__] is that in English meter stick
that's dumb it's a doomstock idiots
and the Steven uses one I don't know
I'm so disappointed someone's been
posting daily quests of PewDiePie 2 for
Simulator for
668 days
[Music]
Jesus Christ
all right that's big PP all right is
that really we need to do a sequel of
that game I feel like it was so fun I
mean it's still really really fun what
do you guys think
laughs
hey 11 you learn right hey you inspired
me to go to the gym three years ago I
never felt better in 2020 I was 310
pounds oh thank you for the kilo thank
you and two years later I have the best
shape of my life that's still uh taking
onwards now 113 kilograms
excellent job like dude keep killing it
amazing progress big baby but to the
2016 tour I've been rocking it I missed
that thing it's so [__] comfy all
right guys great shows great memes
appreciate you start lifting now and
also the sun isn't dangerous it's not
[Applause]